1950 — Alan Turing asks: “Can machines think?”
1950年，艾伦·图灵提问：“机器能思考吗？”
1956 — Dartmouth: AI becomes a field.
1956年，达特茅斯会议：AI成为一门学科。
1958 — The Perceptron learns from examples.
1958年，感知机学会从样本中学习。
1986 — Backprop: networks learn from mistakes.
1986年，反向传播：网络从错误中学习。
1997 — Deep Blue beats Kasparov at chess.
1997年，“深蓝”击败国际象棋冠军卡斯帕罗夫。
2012 — AlexNet: ImageNet error 26% → 15%.
2012年，AlexNet：ImageNet错误率26%→15%。
2016 — AlphaGo beats Lee Sedol 4–1.
2016年，AlphaGo以4:1战胜李世石。
2017 — The Transformer is born.
2017年，Transformer诞生。
2020 — GPT-3: 175 billion parameters.
2020年，GPT-3：1750亿参数。
2022 — ChatGPT: ~100M users in 2 months (est.)
2022年，ChatGPT两个月用户约1亿（估算）。
It reads. It writes. It sees. It codes.
它会读、会写、会看、会编程。
But how does it actually think?
但它究竟是怎么“思考”的？
① Text is chopped into tokens — numbers the model can read.
① 文本被切成token——模型能读懂的数字。
② Each token becomes a vector. Meaning becomes geometry.
② 每个token都变成一个向量，意义变成了几何。
③ Attention: every word looks at every other word for context.
③ 注意力：每个词都会关注其他所有词，寻找上下文。
④ Predict the next token. Then the next. Again and again.
④ 预测下一个token，再下一个，周而复始。
More data. More compute. New abilities emerge.
更多数据，更多算力，新的能力不断涌现。
Frontier training compute has grown about 4–5× per year.
前沿模型的训练算力，大约每年增长4到5倍。
So the question has changed.
于是，问题变了。
Not “Can it think?” — but “What can it do?”
不再是“它能思考吗？”，而是“它能做什么？”
It writes and tests code. It sees. It listens and speaks.
它能写代码、跑测试，能看，能听，也能说。
AlphaFold: 200M+ protein structures predicted.
AlphaFold：已预测超过2亿种蛋白质结构。
2024 — Two Nobel Prizes honor AI breakthroughs.
2024年，两项诺贝尔奖授予AI相关突破。
Diffusion models turn pure noise into images.
扩散模型能把纯噪声变成图像。
Agents plan, use tools, and finish multi-step tasks.
智能体会规划、调用工具，完成多步骤任务。
In labs, classrooms, hospitals and studios — everywhere.
在实验室、课堂、医院和工作室——无处不在。
AI amplifies whoever uses it.
AI会放大每一个使用它的人。
The question is no longer “Can machines think?”
问题不再是“机器能思考吗？”